Guess what?
It's Monday!
it's our favorite day around here
'Cause it's a great way to kickstart the week.
It's time for our pop quiz!
(bell rings)
Okay, our VFF Brenda, you have been selected.
Hi Brenda!
Hi Drew I love you, this is crazy.
(Ross chuckles)
Oh Brenda, I'm so excited that you're here.
And if you answer the three questions about today's show,
you'll win $1,000.
(audience clapping)
But for every question you get right,
Well how much do they get?
A hundred.
You get a hundred dollars!
That's good.
All right, Brenda, are you ready?
Yes Drew, yes, Ross yes.
Okay, here we go!
And First, Leslie Mann revealed she took
up a hobby during the quarantine.
What was that hobby?
I got it!
I got it, she's roller skating with her daughter!
Yes!
(audience cheers)
All right, second question.
(indistinct) was sitting in front of a piece of art
during her interview.
What was on the piece of art?
Oh, it was a portrait of horses.
Yes!
(audience cheers)
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Okay and,
I get so excited I can't even believe it.
Okay finally, there was a makeup palette colab
that we talked about in the news.
What nineties company is in the colab?
I cannot even believe that they're doing that,
it's a blockbuster (indistinct)
(Audience cheering)
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
You did it!
$1000!
(audience clapping)
Oh my gosh, you are so cute, thank you so much.
Oh Brenda, I'm so happy for you and thank you
for not only playing along, but paying such good attention.
Thank you.
And thank you to anyone else who may be kind
enough to be watching.
And certainly all of our VFF's,
our crew who is our family.
And Rossy, thank you.
Thank you Drew, thank you.
We hope you have a wonderful rest of your day.
(audience clapping)
(upbeat cheerful music)